well and let's talk about that because
John Bolton will be in in just a couple
of weeks as the National Security
Advisor we know him well here at FoxNews
he's a real hardliner when it comes to
Iran Amir on nuclear deal that certainly
should be very much in keeping with the
position not only the president but also
Mike Pompeo who's been a hardliner at as
CIA director about the utility of that
deal what can you tell us about John
bolt when it comes to North Korea and
again we're talking about all of this
happening with a summit and of course
things can be delayed but a summit that
is supposed to take place according to
the president some time by the end of
May well there's no greater hardliner on
North Korea than John Bolton
we've known an ambassador Bolton for a
long time if you look at the Wall Street
Journal he wrote an op-ed recently
called the legal case for striking North
Korea first so he has put out there the
potential for a preemptive strike
against North Korea I've heard of him
say on many occasions that he does not
think that talking to North Korea will
work it will not lead to
denuclearization of the peninsula John
Bolton was involved in in the 90s where
you know he was burned by the North
Koreans in the past and so he is not
somebody who is going to who is going to
trust that talks are going to lead to
the denuclearization also we have a very
important date coming up in May in terms
of the Iran deal the president has
indicated that he may may let that that
deal lapse and I certainly think that
John Bolton would agree with him on that
you have a real daisy-chain of changes
within the national security roles
surrounding the president and it
certainly is leaning more towards a
allowing the Iran deal to lapse and a
hard line on North Korea well let me
just pick up one more time with you on
that
Jennifer in terms of the hard line
towards North Korea is that going to be
a hard line but still a summit or is
that there's such a hard line that the
Ambassador Bultman to some degree we're
speculating here might be trying to
persuade the president not to sit down
with Kim jong-un from what was going to
be an absolutely unprecedented meeting
the first time that any American
president
devran that with the North Korean leader
I think it would be hard for the
president to back out of that meeting at
this point you heard the president of
South Korea offered for it to be perhaps
a trilateral meeting between the two
between the three countries so the South
Korean president would be there at the
same time but I certainly think that
with John Bolton advising the president
that it is unlikely that that it would
be a long diplomatic process that they
would enter into John Bolton is very
suspicious of that kind of long process
he's seeing how that is used as a
stalling mechanism by groups such as
North Korea what is not clear to me is
that if you let the Iran deal lapse how
do you turn to the North Koreans and
negotiate any sort of settlement with
them believing that that the US would in
fact live up to an agreement and that's
going to be that that's the biggest
argument among nuclear experts as to how
you go into the North Korea nuclear
talks if you let the Iran deal lapse
thanks so much at a further I want you
standby and if you can come up with any
more information let us know we'll bring
you back in let's turn now to chief
intelligence correspondent Catherine
Herridge Catherine obviously you have
great sources and the intelligence
community did you get any sense from
them as I say obviously there had been
talk about McMaster out there had been
talk about John Bolton coming in but
late last week or over the weekend it
seemed that that was all going to be on
hold for a while now suddenly it isn't a
circus I've seen John Bolton I hear Fox
News yesterday and I think in fact
earlier today and he's I want to
emphasize always been very discreet but
any kind of discussions he may or may
not be having about entering the White
House I agree with Jennifer when you
look at this shift in the context of the
other changes to the cabinet that the
president has now put forward on on Iran
I think you've given that a good
treatment the odds of the u.s. pulling
out of the deal have gone way up
ambassador Bolton has never been a
proponent of the deal that was struck
under the Obama administration if you
look at the issue of Russia ambassador
Bolton is seen as someone who is calling
for a very aggressive policy with the
Russians in fact just on his Twitter
account
in the last few days he posted about how
flat Amir Putin had been able to
probably use kind of an information
warfare campaign on his own people in
order to ensure victory and then he
could take that
so sarcastically speaking and apply it
to the United States and other countries
so he's advocating a pretty aggressive
position or a more aggressive position
with Russia and then on China he also
was tweeting about the need for a more
aggressive posture which would of course
be in line with the imposition of
terrorists that the president did today
I want to say though sort of on a
personal note it does appear to me that
he would have sort of a good sort of
chemistry or connection with the
president especially on the issue of the
special counsel and related discussions
I know from speaking to ambassador
Bolton on a number of occasions that he
was deeply distressed by the unmasking
controversy and the extent to which
members of the Obama administration were
unmasking individuals either directly in
the Trump campaign or associated with
the Trump campaign in the 2016 election
he said to me that in the years that he
had that ability in the intelligence
community he only did it a handful of
times and he felt that it was beyond
shocking that the former UN Ambassador
it was alleged had unmasked made a
number of unmasking requests upwards of
200 in the calendar year of 2016 and
then also as a final point he was very
distressed about the Special Counsel
investigation in light of what he saw as
a double standard with the handling of
the Clinton email case under FBI
director James Comey so a lot of
agreement that he's going to be more
aggressive more hawkish he was very
discreet about any discussions but
certainly would have a lot of common
ground with the President on those key
issues the special counsel and then also
the unmasking which would be outside of
his purview as the national security
adviser Chris Catherine thanks so much